I had to stop my fed med and I've erected protocol because my kidney numbers were too high,
but my live blood analysis practitioner still sees parasites in my blood, so he wants me to try
to elbedozole 400 milligrams twice a day, but only one day a week. I read that you need to keep an eye
on your liver numbers for this medication also, but I'm wondering if this dosage
at this frequency is small enough that I should not have to worry about it. Well, again,
there's no way that anybody can say yes or no to that. You'd have to keep an eye on your number,
so if the fed med is all is what is causing too much of a rise in your kidney numbers,
the albedozole is going to do the exact same thing, so it's in that same family, it's going to do
that same thing, but because you're only doing it once a week, maybe that would help. Well,
maybe yeah, the only way to know is to look at your blood work again, so that's the only way to
answer that question.